. Let's go next to our caller from the six
4 six area code who's calling today from 6
4 6.
Is that me?
Yes, it is.
Hello.
OK.
So first off, I love your show.
I've been listening for a while and I subscribed
and everything and I'm old enough to say this.
If I had a son, I'd want it to be you.
You're pretty awesome.
Thank you.
Here's my question.
Here's my question for you.
As we move into this election and watching
what's going on with these daily press briefings,
but you're just getting crazier and crazier
by the day.
Yep.
My question for you is relating to propaganda.
So do you think.
And I just don't have a handle on this.
Do you think these.
Like, do you think the way that Trump is approaching
this, this.
Because basically it's a propaganda song.
It's like right out of 1984, half of what
he's doing like wrong is right.
Leftist.
You know, work will make you free, et cetera,
et cetera.
Do you think that this has any effect that
will help him win the election on anything
other than the base?
I don't know the answer to that.
And the reason that I don't know the answer
to that is ultimately I believe that the election
is going to depend on what is the general
perception of how he handled the virus.
He clearly realizes and the people around
him realize that that is a propaganda fight
to be had.
So they now are, you know, playing highlight
videos during press briefings.
They are just telling lies.
They're skipping the month of February altogether
in their explanation of how well they do.
So Trump knows that it's going to be a propaganda
war around the virus if the virus is out of
control in November.
You would think that would be bad for Trump,
except if you you have to go out to vote.
That's going to be good for Trump because
it's the Trump ists who are going to ignore
stay at home orders and go out to vote, whereas
Democrats are more likely to take them seriously.
So it's such a mess that I have no idea how
this is all going to affect the November election.
I couldn't tell you.
Well, I just I find it really hard to get
a read on because, I mean, I'm gonna go there.
So, I mean, I've read a lot of, you know,
history of Germany in the thirties and the
Nazi Party and gerbils, et cetera, et cetera.
And it seems like a lot of the techniques
that he's using are very similar to like Nazi
propaganda techniques.
Except that it seemed at that point the overwhelming
majority of Germans kind of went along with
that propaganda and supported it.
And I'm seeing much more resistance in this
country.
So it's really hard for me to get a read on
whether it's working or not, because I'm trying
to figure out, is the base enough?
And I got in my bones.
I feel like if the base just votes for him,
that's not enough for him to win.
Right.
So here's the answer.
We don't have mandatory voting in the country.
Roughly half the country doesn't vote.
So the base is enough.
Right.
If a bunch of people stay home and don't vote.
That's that.
That's the unfortunate reality.
What you're.
So the techniques being used by Trump knowingly
or unknowingly are reminiscent of some of
what we saw in the pre-World War 2 Germany
phase.
That doesn't mean Trump is Hitler.
Right.
To be clear, that's not what we're saying.
No, of course not.
I'm calling because we haven't had because
we have independent media alternatives to
Trump.
Trump's propaganda, his base is highly propagandized,
right.
Ninety nine.
They'd never abandon him that that contingent.
But then you've got a whole bunch of other.
No.
And they never will.
You've got a whole bunch of other people who
don't fall for it.
The question is, are they going to go out
and vote in November?
And I just don't have the answer.
I don't know.
OK.
I mean, and I mean, that's basically it.
I mean, the only other thing that I would
say is I feel like nothing that he's doing
is moving the needle on independence or getting
people to vote.
In other words, I think that he's doing indicates
to me that he is getting new votes or getting
people to change their mind.
So that leaves it to the base.
I guess you're right.
And but part of me also is like because I've
had these conversations with about five or
six different people.
We're talking about people that voted for
Jill Stein.
People that voted third party in the last
election.
And they said to me, guess what?
Not making that mistake again.
So I'm wondering if there are a number of
people that, quote, took a chance on him and
then decide they are now like, oh, my God,
this is a nightmare.
That's not going to happen.
We'll know when we get the 2020 exit polls.
But in the meantime, the sort of turnout idea
that you're talking about, the political scientist
Rachel BYT Coffer has written about this quite
a bit.
And we're going to interview her on the show
very soon.
And it's a it's it's about turnout ultimately
is what you're saying.
And I tend to agree with you.
Excellent.
Well, I look forward to that interview and
love the show and I'm happy to be a supporter.
Thank you so much.
I so appreciate it.
Great to hear from you and hope to hear from
you again.